est ce que vous pensez à aller au drive
in
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une intimité à l'intérieur d'une
voiture
qui est pas du tout la même que celle
qu'on peut vivre dans une salle de
cinéma
[Musique]
j'avais trouvé sa sensationnelle ça
correspondait vraiment à une forme
nouvelle du cinéma classique et quand je
suis rentré en france
un jour je me suis posé la question mais
pourquoi n'y at il pas des drive-in en
france
[Musique]
je vois que décidément c'est le cinéma
des chiens possibilité de l'amener
d'ailleurs dans ces conditions là
c'est agréable on est en famille on peut
fumer on peut parler on peut commenter
le film sans déranger les voisins
seul inconvénient pour l'hiver c'est
qu'on aura beaucoup de vue et ce n'est
pas aux prises je pensais le drive in
madam est ce que vous pensez à l'est au
drive in
[Musique]